il y a eu un énorme tremblement de terre
aux nord-est du japon aujourd'hui la
centrale nucléaire de fukushima daiichi
est en situation critique
monsieur le président c'est extrêmement
grave
il y un avertissement de méga tsunami
[Musique]
si le courant n'est pas rétabli à temps
le coeur va fusionner ce serait une
catastrophe
il est nécessaire de relâcher un peu de
pression quelqu'un doit entrer dans le
bâtiment du réacteur contaminés le
niveau de radiation est élevé on doit
décider qui va le faire si vous êtes
prêt à vous porter volontaire payé lever
la main oui j'y vais aussi envoyer les i
moi aussi
ceux qui sont sur place risquent leur
vie
elle peut éclater à tout moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis né ici et j'ai grandi ici je
ferai tout pour sauver cet endroit